hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast the clinical impact and
implementation of T to M R and the T to
Candida panel and the management of
Canada Mia at a large tertiary care
Health System
I am Kristen Perez and he loved lab
roots and I'll be your moderator for
today's event we are delighted to bring
you this educational webinar presented
by lab roots for more information please
visit lab rat scum this event is
sponsored by t2 bio Systems Inc t2 bio
systems is focused on developing
innovative diagnostic products to
improve patient health with two
fda-cleared products targeting sepsis
and a range of additional products in
development t2 bio systems is an
emerging leader in the field of in vitro
diagnostics we have a few important
announcements before we begin this
webinar is designed to be interactive
and we encourage you to ask questions
during the event you can submit
questions by typing them in the Q&A box
which can be found by clicking on the
green Q&A button at the lower left of
the presentation window we'll try to
answer as many questions as we can you
can enlarge the slide window by clicking
on the screen icon in the lower right
hand corner of the slide window if you
have any technical problems viewing or
hearing this presentation please click
on the support button at the top right
of your presentation window or submit
your problem through the green Q&A
button lower left this is an education
webinar and thus offers free continuing
education credit after the webinar click
on the C e button located in the bottom
left hand corner of your webpage and
follow the process of obtaining your
credit and I would like to now introduce
today's speaker dr. George Allen Gavin
dr. Allen Gannon received his medical
degree from the University of Bombay and
has since completed postgraduate
training in India the United Kingdom and
the United States dr. Allen Gannon is
the director of transplant infectious
infectious diseases and director of
infection control and prevention at
Henry Ford Hospital and transplant into
the
- dr. Allen Ganon's research interest
lies in the epidemiology and outcome of
infections in Nina compromised patients
and transplant recipients he is also
involved in well published in the areas
of research related to tuberculosis and
knows the communal infection especially
Clostridium difficile later during the
Q&A portion of today's webinar dr. Allan
Gannon will be joined by his colleagues
dr. Leno Samuel and dr. Rachel Kenny who
will jointly respond to today's question
manoj samuel is the division head of
clinical microbiology at Henry Ford
Health System dr. samuel completed his
fellowship in clinical microbiology and
public health at the University of
Rochester in Rochester New York and has
been serving as the division head of
clinical microbiology at Henry Ford
Health System since 2007 Rachael Kenny
is a pharmacy specialist in
antimicrobial Jewish stewardship at
Henry Ford Hospital in Detroit Michigan
where she also serves as residency
program director from the postgraduate
year to infectious diseases pharmacy
residency Rachel received her doctor of
pharmacy degree from the University of
Michigan College of Pharmacy completed a
PG y1 pharmacy practice residency at
Detroit receiving hospital in Detroit
Michigan and a PG Y to residency in
infectious diseases at Maya clinic
Rachael's clinical and research
interests include antimicrobial
stewardship and antimicrobial medication
safety I will now turn it over to dr.
Ellen cotton for his presentation hello
everyone welcome it's my pleasure today
to present p2m our implementation and
impact on the management of Candida Mia
and the Henry Ford Health System the
Henry Ford Health System comprises of
both acute care hospitals and 42
ambulatory centers and afforded the main
hospitals based in urban
Detroit it has eight hundred acute care
beds and includes 142 ICU beds and is a
tertiary care teaching hospital the
hospital also includes the Cancer Center
and a transplant Institute and the
central microbiology laboratory is
located at Henry Ford main so my
disclosure statement I receive grants
support from milk and I'm a consultant
to Astellas pharmaceuticals and t2 bio
systems my colleagues who will join us
during the Q&A session dr. Leonard
Samuel and Rachel Kim my intent is to
help you understand the process for
implementation of t2 Amman and the t2
candida panel at the Henry Ford Health
System and also understand the impact of
t2 candida panel on the management of
patients with Candida Mia at Henry Ford
Health System as we all know there are
several challenges to the management of
Candida meum the clinical features of
Candida Nia are hard to distinguish from
those caused by bacteria there are no
reliable clinical prediction models for
the detection of can anemia even though
some models exist for ICU patients and
neutropenic patients these are not
consistently reliable we all realize
that blood culture has a sensitivity of
38% to 83% for the detection of Candida
Mia and moreover candida Mia is
associated with crude mortality rates in
excess of almost 50 percent as a result
of the significant mortality associated
with delay in diagnosis this is led to
the use of empiric antifungal therapy in
what we term as high-risk patients
when we examined our own best practices
for the management of surface suspected
candy Demian prior to the implementation
of p2 mr we designed it using an
algorithm for easy implementation in a
patient who is suspected with to have
candy delia which was defined as the
persistence of fever of features of
senses while the patient is on adequate
antibiotic therapy for at least 72 hours
and has a candida scope now the
candidates Co of three was based on a
predictive model that includes variables
such as severe sepsis it receives a
score of two TPN surgery multifocal
Candida colonization all of which
receive a score of one in these patients
where you suspect candy Demian our
practice is to obtain two sets of blood
cultures and at that time we were using
two serial bitterly glucan assays of fun
details they were sent to a reference
lab for testing in the meantime the
clinician was permitted to initiate
empirically formal therapy if the
patient had features of severe sepsis
typically for an ICU patient we would
have used a Nadella function which is a
broad-spectrum anticlinal kandan and
antifungal agent that treats almost all
species of Candida if this was a general
practice unit patient where Candida
albicans is by far the most common
pathogens then clinicians would often
use fluconazole subsequently if the
blood culture was positive or the
beetling look at as a result was
positive and the patient was on
antifungal therapy we will modify the
antifungal therapy based on
identification of the candida species
and the availability of
stability testings on the other hand if
the blood cultures were negative and the
beta-d-glucose si also was negative we
would prompt the clinician to stop every
candy from those therapy now once we
implemented this and had it running for
a couple of years we realized they were
certain challenges with the use of the
meat early glucan fun details acid what
we ran into was a high rate of false
positive results now the typical normal
range of beta glucan ranges from 60 to
80 micrograms per ml we increase this
cutoff to a cutoff for 200 micrograms
per ml based on a hospital beta that it
was more specific however we still had a
high false positive rate despite this
higher cutoff the second issue we were
running into is the frontal acid was a
send of disk and with on an average take
about four to five days for a result to
be available furthermore there was no
speciation of the type of Candida
species that was isolated from the fund
Eitan acid and we could not modify our
initial antifungal therapy so this led
us still looking at new new avenues and
recent technology which is a t2 mr and
we considered implementing it at the
Henry Ford Health System the rationale
for using t2 amar was 1 clinical trials
have suggested that the t2 mr candida
added as a sensitivity of 91% and a
specificity of 99% for the diagnosis of
Candida mia moreover it had a negative
predictive value of 99% for ruling out
candy deviance furthermore it permitted
speciation of the candidate
as it could detect the five Candida
species that were commonly isolated in
clinical practice so we could modify
empiric therapy accordingly and finally
and most importantly we could bring the
testing in-house so that we could have a
rapid turnaround time compared to the
functional assays that were sent out
through a reference lab now we
anticipated that there would be some
impact both clinically on a stewardship
program as well as on a lab the clinical
impact that we anticipated was that the
rapid detection of Candida Mia using T
to Emma and the speciation of the
candida species could result in early
initiation of appropriate antifungal
therapy and we thought this might lead
to improved patient outcomes namely
mortality we also anticipated there
might be an overall reduction in the
length of stayin with an early
identification of infection and possibly
an impact on the ICU length of stay the
antimicrobial stewardship impact would
result from prompt discontinuation of
antifungal therapy and the ability to
deescalate from a broad spectrum and
expensive ages and Adella funded the
fluconazole therapy for species of
Canada that were susceptible and this
could result in potential cost savings
for the limb for the pharmacy on the
laboratory the impact will be primarily
discontinuation of the send out for
detailed testing resulting in possible
cost savings this best practice
initiative for the management of candida
Mia was primarily driven by infectious
diseases and the pharmacy antimicrobial
stewardship program and microbiology the
other stakeholders included leadership
from physicians nursing and
demonstration the next few slides I'll
discuss and overview the implementation
of t2 Emma's at Henry Ford Health System
the first and most important step was
education that was primarily done by the
antimicrobial stewardship pharmacists
the Department of Microbiology
and the division of infectious diseases
and it targeted physicians nurses and
pharmacists at all of the business units
within the Henry Ford Health System the
messaging was provided through
electronic newsletters clinical meetings
and during rounds and the key messages
were one when to test and whom to test
proper sample collection and most
importantly what were the clinical
implications of a positive or a negative
t2m our test result in the laboratory
the implementation involved in we
implemented a test in November of 2015
and the funded health testing for
Candida Mia was gradually phased out
over the next several months the
pharmacy aspects of implementation
involved some building of ordering
increase in an electronic medical
records so if a clinician made a request
for a needler sponges the order set
included checkboxes for an IV
consultation for the t2 mr orders as
well as blood culture orders when the
t2m our results were available in real
time would generate an alert for the
antimicrobial stewardship pharmacist in
tarragon which is a clinical
surveillance software system that's used
at a sentence
some additional details about
implementation of testing in the
clinical laboratory the initial step
include an assessment of the lab flow
with the implementation of T to a month
there were several rounds of validation
of the testing done in the laboratory
the testing was done only at the central
lab house and the main Hospital in
Detroit p2m our testing was done from 7
a.m. to 10 p.m.
samples received after 10 p.m. were
tested the next day and testing was
provided 24/7 we established certain
parameters 42m our testing we tested
patients with suspected candida Mia or
in raisered candidiasis using some of
the clinical criteria that i discussed
earlier the recommendations were to draw
the t to mr and blood cultures always
from a peripheral blood drop to avoid
detection of colonization of central
lines to draw blood cultures and t to a
mas simultaneously whenever possible now
in event of a negative T to our mr
result testing was permitted after seven
days here there was clinical worsening
and we discourage test of kill for using
T 2 mr so the new algorithm for the
management of suspected candida Mia
since the implementation of T 2 mr it's
similar to the one that i discussed
earlier except one detail was removed
from our testing and replaced by t2 em
up so to quickly walk you through this
patients with suspected
and anemia would get two sets of blood
cultures and a person blood draw 42 a
month the clinician could initiate the
patient of empiric antifungal therapy if
senior centers and subsequently if a
blood culture or a t2 amount as a result
was positive the antifungal therapy if
it had been started could be modified
quickly based on the species
identification on p2 a month and
subsequent susceptibility testing from
blood cultures when available on the
other hand with blood cultures and p2
Amar's
assays were negative we recommended
stopping entering antifungal therapy
in addition patients who had a positive
blood culture or a t2 amount acid an ID
consultation was recommended and
ophthalmology thing I exam was requested
five to seven days after detection of
candida mia to identify any high
involvement from the candida mia namely
retinitis or botrytis clinicians were
encouraged to remove IV lines if that
was suspected to be the source of the
candida mia and repeat blood cultures or
obtained after starting therapy to
document clearance of and email what
I've shown here is an example is a
screen shot of an animal of function on
the panel that is baked into a ordered
set in the electronic medical records as
you can see above is the order for a
medulla pungent and included it in this
ordered set what's the T - Elmer order
this was built in so that the clinicians
could check the source at the time of
requesting and
love function and as Rachel will
emphasize to you later
this was an important step in our
algorithm to ensure compliance so at
this time I have given you an overview
and some details about the
implementation of the t2m our systems
and the tea to Canada panel at Henry
Ford Health System and during the Q&A
session we'll have an opportunity to
talk in more depth with Rachel and Minaj
about challenges and process
improvements to this process the second
half of my presentation will discuss the
impact on the management of cavity Nia
and our early experience this work was
done primarily by the pharmacy under the
direction of Rachel Kenny so this study
examined the impact of p2m our
implementation and the use of fetal
Candida famine and the improvement in
the timely management of Canada me the
study design was a single pretest
postage for the experiment the study
population included all patients at
Henry Ford Health System that were
diagnosed with Candida Mia from April
2015 until May 2016 using either blood
cultures Peter Lee glucan or t2 Emma the
theta abstraction was done from
electronic medical records using a
standardized case reporting form that
included patient demographics risk
factors for Candida Mia diagnostic
information the treatment and management
and outcomes
andddd testicle analysis were used to
characterize the patient population as
well as the other outcome results the
primary end points of the study was one
time to appropriate antifungal therapy
that was defined as the time of life lab
orders for the diagnostic test until the
time to initiation of antifungal therapy
the second primary end point was timed
to detection of CAD edenia define as the
time of a live lab order to the time of
the first actionable result the
secondary end points included overall
length of stay and ICU length of stage
after the onset of candid email it also
included complications of Candida Mia
causing retinitis or botrytis in the eye
and all cause crude in hospital
mortality we do not assess mortality
attributable to candid even shown here
are the results when we examine the time
endpoints in the 3t 2mr period and the
post P to a month period we can see that
the time to appropriate antifungal
therapy was significantly shortened in
the post T 2mr period from almost 40
hours in the volatile period to 26 hours
on 27 hours in the post T 2mr period and
this works fantastically significant
examining time to detection of Candida
species there's also a significant
impacted by t2 Amaro and it decreased
from approximately 42 hours in the
preety to a mob period to 25 hours in
the post p2m our implementation period
now the additional things that I wanted
to discuss in the time to detection of
Candida species in the Polsky to amount
period when we examined the turnaround
time in only the p2m our group excluding
blood cultures that turnaround time was
even shorter it was seven hours and this
could in fact clinical management length
of stay and other variables so the total
length of stage was not statistically
significant however it had decreased
from 13 hours to nine ounce more
importantly the ICU length of state
declined from 13 hours to 6 hours and
this was toggling significant it is
unclear at this time the association of
this reduction in ICU length of stay and
t2 mr and we examining additional
variables that could have affected this
positive impact we also examined ocular
candidal involvement and this decreased
from 30% in the brief t2 mr period to 8%
in the 42 mr period i have hypothesis is
that possibly earlier detection by t2 a
mark at a low level of detection
resulted in prompt therapy and this
needs further investigation
as you can see there was no significant
impact on mortality the mortality as you
realize with a hard endpoint as these
ICU patients have greater severity of
illness and largest studies would be
needed to explode this
at any point in addition to the previous
study we also examine the impact of a
negative p2m our result on antifungals
twinship there were 155 patients who
were identified with a negative T to a
marathon antifungals were given to 49 of
these 155 patients while the T to a mod
result was pending as you can see there
was a positive impact or 94 those to
mention the average based on antifungal
therapy in those 49 patients was one day
with a range of 1 to 3 days
the clinical response to a negative T to
a mod result 71 percent of patients the
enteric antifungal therapy was
discontinued on receiving a negative T
to Amman result in another 4% we were
able to deescalate Anabella fudgin to
fluconazole based on the candida species
identification provided by T to Emma
however a quarter of the patients the
therapy there was no change and this
certainly needs to be examined further
now we also learned some important
lessons along the way we realized a
large proportion of our patients who had
candida Nia detected by either blood
culture or t2 amar did not fit the
traditional profile as shown by the
candida scoring system that used so it
was important for us to maintain a high
index of suspicion for Candida man in
patients with senses even though they
may not have met a candidate score of
greater than or equal to 3 we also saw
discordant results between t2 NMR that
emphasizes in
important to drop paid sentence to draw
samples before administration of
antifungal therapy so always the Paracel
blood draws to avoid colonization that
might exist in central lines and
progress skin cleansing because being a
very sensitive PCR test this might lead
to contamination during collection of
blood samples he also realized it's
critical to do continuous quality
monitoring of the test performance in
the laboratory and furthermore we needed
to re-emphasize discontinuation of
antifungals if blood cultures and t2m
our results were negative and some of
these performance quality measures will
have a chance to discuss them during our
Q&A session now the limitations of the
study include this is a single Center
experience this is very early experience
it's a new novel test and there's always
a learning curve the interpretation of a
positive p2m are in the absence of a
positive blood culture is still
challenging there was non uniformity of
blood collection in the real life
settings that could have impacted this
and blood culture which is considered a
gold standard itself may be too
insensitive the kind of give us the true
meaning of a positively to a math test
so in summary our early experience after
implementation of t2 Lamar and the t2
candidate panel at the Henry Ford Health
System appears very promising p2m our
implementation was associated with
significant reduction in time to
detection of candy demon it improved
significantly time to initiation of
antifungal therapy unnecessary
antifungals were rapidly discontinued in
almost three quarters of the
it resulted in reduced I see a length of
state there were fewer patients who had
involvement of the eye with something
from candy demian however there was no
significant difference in mortality some
of our early experience was presented at
ID week and I've shown you here the
abstracts that were presented that I
would discussed in this presentation
thank you all for your attention
it was a pleasure to discuss my
experience with him thank you for that
informative presentation dr. Alan Gannon
before we get started on the
question-and-answer session I would like
to remind our audience how to submit
questions you can submit questions by
typing them in the Q&A box which can be
found by clicking on the green Q&A
button at the lower left of the
presentation window we'll try to answer
as many questions as you can
I will now turn it over to dr. Allen
Gannon Samuel and Kenny to take
questions
hello everyone
at this time I would like to invite our
panelists dr. Rachel Kane and Daniel to
join the discussion and I will start
with Rachel so later when you look back
at our experience how cost effective is
assessed in our experience I can speak a
little bit to the pharmacy return on
investment in avoided anti-fungal useful
though we haven't done a formal economic
analysis our animate for real
stewardship program did conduct an
internal medication youth evaluation of
70 patients to determine the downstream
impact of a negative t2m are on
antifungal therapy and when we compared
to our own historical data we
estimate that the t2m are allows us to
rule out candid emia and approximately a
hundred and forty patients per year and
compared to our old standard of care
that translated to an avoidance of
approximately six amygdala funds and
maintenance doses for each of those 140
patients so when you assume an average
wholesale price of about one hundred and
eighty dollars per initial assange and
dose that could translate into a much as
much as a hundred and fifty thousand
dollars per year in avoided a kind of
candan cost so as many of you realize
the implementation of a new test in a
large healthcare system presents
challenges so Rachel what will
challenges to the implementation of T to
Emma from a pharmacy and antimicrobial
stewardship standpoint I think for us
given the size of our institution
implementing effective education is
always a challenge we knew that we
needed to educate nurses pharmacists
prescribers or microbiology staff and we
knew that we wanted to emphasize a few
key educational messages including when
the test would be clinically indicated
how to properly collect the test
specimen and the clinical implications
and how to respond to those positive and
negative tests great what do you think
should be the key messages from the
pharmacy and antimicrobial stewardship
standpoint for any institution
considering implementation of T to Emma
so as I mentioned education was one of
our biggest challenges and also
absolutely essential but we recognized
that in addition to a couple of rounds
of Education we needed some strategies
that would be a little more sustained I
think one of the most important
strategies we use was the creation of
the order panel in the electronic health
record and that helps maximize our
adherence to the guideline
so that we can accomplish both prompt
empiric antifungal therapy and obtains
the most appropriate diagnostic tests in
a timely fashion but even with a
guideline all of our education the best
practice hardwired into our electronic
health record I would say that our time
to antifungal therapy is still not where
we want it to be so measuring and
continuing to refine and look for new
ways to improve is also another key step
to success I'm so subsequently we've
worked with our electronic health record
programmers to ensure that our economy
and in loading doses always default to
stat and our microbiology lab as kind of
a second phase of our rollout is now
calling positive t2 results as a
critical value just like they would with
any other blood culture that was very
informative Rachel if I can now turn to
dr. Samuel Vinod as the director of the
microbiology lab what would the
laboratory challenges with
implementation of the t2m our taste
so what couple of challenges we faced
was this is a novel assay and to
leverage the maximum efficacy of tests
of the testing platform we had to run
this at least across two shifts to
provide timely results and although it
is a cartridge rate assay we felt we
needed to treat this like a crucial
month or at it we had non molecule
trained Tech's running this assay and we
we went through several rounds of
training by the company staff over the
course of the first couple of months we
felt this was absolutely essential to
avoiding contamination issues that might
occur during the testing process and
that did on occasion occur so it is
absolutely important that ticks are
trained well and that there's monitoring
of the positive result that coming off
machine to look for usual patterns in
test results and and to ensure the death
of following appropriate protocols as
needed we also emphasize took some
additional steps to reduce the risk of
contamination such as use of a dead air
box to prepare specimens and also using
disposable materials and pads for each
specimen separately when we were setting
them up as Rachel mentioned we didn't
start off drinking this is a critical
value but we did transition to you're
treating this as a critical value so
usually those are called as they come
off the machine and we also looked at we
didn't look at a rate of invalids and we
do not see the higher level of invalid
result pedals in your clinical trials
that was something that initiative an
area of concern for us but we did not
have that happen
great you know it now we all realize
that p2m are is not an inexpensive test
so how would you address the cost
justification of the test in the
clinical laboratory so this was the
challenging this is where we had to
partner with our ID and pharmacy
colleagues we did see some cost savings
because we were we had significant
volume of fungal antigen testing being
sent out and and that gave us some
significant savings but that alone is
not enough to add off of the COS
audacity and so I think that's where the
laboratories look to the clinical
colleagues to show cost savings from
patient care perspective and micro usage
perspective etc to cost justify the
instruments and finally
often it's important to have a
multidisciplinary team to successfully
implement any change so how did the lab
partner with clinical colleagues to
effectively implement the t2m our tests
yeah so again this was a collaboration
ship with ID and pharmacy and given the
expense of running the test we
to ensure appropriate test utilization
and we work with them to set up the
criteria for frequency of testing the
criteria for selecting patients for
testing and then once a patient is
positive house frequently to repeat and
I think those are all institution
specific decisions that need to be made
locally because there are no guidelines
to support you so those are things we do
work with done we also reached out to
nursing councils and we did a lot of
education through nursing councils to
each other this is a novel test not
something that they were used to
ordering and I think part of the issues
of the wine contamination is ensuring
that specifically appropriately we
recommend that they avoid lines for
example avoid and the instrument really
requires the correct amount of loss
samples we draw on volume of sample to
be drawn in the tube as well and so
those are issues that will reduce the
number of invalid or residual samples as
well great Thank You Rachel
Thank You Lee noise thank you
I would like to once again thank dr.
Alan Gannon for his presentation do you
have any final comments for us oh I
would say over the course of this
presentation and the Q&A session I hope
we have given you an understanding of
the successful implementation of t2 mr
and the t2 Canada panel at Henry Ford
Health System and I've also provided an
understanding of the positive impact the
t2 candidate panel had on the management
of patients with Candida Mia at Henry
Ford Hospital so thank you all
wonderful thank you today's webinar will
be available for on-demand viewing
through November of 2017 you will
receive an email from laborat
you when it will be available for replay
we invite you to forward that
announcement to your colleagues you may
have missed today's live event we'll see
you next time goodbye